لقد حصلنا على نظرة لم يسبق لها مثيل
على حطام تيتانيك في
أعماق المحيط الأطلسي ، إنه أول
مسح رقمي بالحجم الكامل وربما
أشهر سفينة في التاريخ للعلماء الأكاديميين
نفذت ما يسمونه أكبر
مشروع مسح تحت الماء في التاريخ
هذا هو  إنه أمر لا يصدق أن نراه مثل
هذا ، إنه التوأم الذي يصنع
توأمًا رقميًا لرف تيتانيك مع
وضوح لا يصدق ، تم إجراء المسح في
الصيف الماضي بواسطة Magellan ، وهي
شركة لرسم خرائط أعماق البحار في Atlantic Productions ،
وهي تقوم بعمل فيلم وثائقي أخذوا
أكثر من 700  ألف صورة قاموا
بتصميمها ثلاثية الأبعاد على أمل أن
تقدم إجابات جديدة عما حدث
عندما غرقت تيتانيك في
رحلتها الأولى في عام 1912 بعد اصطدامها بجبل جليدي
أدى إلى مقتل أكثر من 1500 شخص.